[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
interview politique mon invité ce soir
Emmanuel Denis bonsoir bonsoir mère
écologiste de tours on va parler avec
vous de la transition écologique quelle
solution à l'échelle d'une ville pour
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
et ses conséquences c'est ce qu'on va
voir ensemble mais d'abord le
gouvernement a annoncé aujourd'hui toute
une série de mesures pour réduire notre
consommation énergétique de 10% pour
éviter les coupures d'électricité on va
citer quelques-unes interdiction
d'éclairage des magasins entre une heure
et 6h du matin ça c'est obligatoire
c'est la loi limiter la température à 18
degrés dans les bâtiments en cas de
grande tension énergétique incitation
financière au covoiturage limitation de
la vitesse des voitures de service pour
les agents à 110 km/h sur autoroute
incitation financière pour le
télétravail des fonctionnaires etc ces
mesures qui ressemblent beaucoup
finalement cette prise par les communes
vous paraissez à la hauteur suffisante
pour passer l'hiver alors pour passer
l'hiver j'espère oui
effectivement nous on l'avait pris déjà
ces mesures sur la réduction de
l'éclairage des bâtiments publics on a
vérifié je suis passé dans les rues de
Tours à 1h du matin pour vérifier que
les commerçants étaient nés leurs
enseignes c'est pas c'est pas nickel
d'ailleurs mais donc on va s'occuper de
ça on va réduire aussi la température
dans les piscines d'un degré réduire
tout ajuster à 19 degrés comme c'est
indiqué par le gouvernement donc c'est
des mesures effectivement qui vont nous
aider à faire quelques économies mais on
n'est pas dans un plan de sobriété qui
nous permettra vraiment de faire la
transition énergétique parce que si on
est on fait des économies de 10% par
contre l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie pour une ville comme tour et
pour de nombreux habitants c'est plus de
100% c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir faire
deux et demi
qui trouve grâce à vos yeux le
covoiturage par exemple avec une
incitation financière le covoiturage
c'est une bonne idée et ça tombe bien
puisque justement la métropole avait
lancé avec Clax site un site de
covoiturage donc cette incitation avec
un chèque bonus c'est plutôt une très
bonne idée c'est des solutions bien sûr
qu'il faut développer pour la transition
pour la faire la révolution des
mobilités c'est plus de marche à pied
plus de vélo plus de transport en commun
et plus de covoiturage donc c'est c'est
plutôt une bonne initiative pour inciter
à au moins remplir les voitures quand on
doit faire rouler des voitures vous avez
énuméré un certain nombre de
dispositions que vous avez prises pour
faire des économies dans un premier
temps quel est l'objectif justement pour
la ville de Tours en termes d'économie
bah c'est aussi de faire aux alentours
de de 5 à 10% d'économie sur un budget
qui va passer de 4 millions en 2019
année de référence à 10 millions si on
ne fait rien donc l'objectif ce serait
de gagner entre 500 à 1 million de
d'euros sur cette facture énergétique
avec aussi des mesures comme le retarder
l'allumage des du chauffage dans les
bâtiments publics bon alors là on est un
peu aidé par le temps le réchauffement
climatique a aussi cet intérêt là donc
ça va nous permettre et on l'espère de
gagner 5 à 10% mais là encore ça sera
pas suffisant pour faire la vraie
transition énergétique qui l'a est
nécessaire et qui nécessite des gros
investissements à court terme parce
qu'il faut s'attendre à d'autres mesures
d'urgence des fermetures d'établissement
piscine gymnase par exemple alors c'est
ce qu'on essaye d'éviter c'est pour ça
que on a pris ces mesures immédiates
d'économies par contre c'est sûr que si
on est dans un une spirale de crise
énergétique avec des coûts qui
commencent à augmenter malheureusement
il y a un moment les services publics
vont être atteints c'est vraiment ce que
on essaye d'éviter c'est pour ça qu'on
prend ces mesures c'est pour ça que
parallèlement on a un plan de sobriété
qui est en train d'être travaillé mais
bâtiments communaux pour la ville de
Tours on a 400 400 bâtiments communaux
on a 58 groupes scolaires on a plusieurs
piscines on a plusieurs dizaines de
gymnases donc oui de nombreux bâtiments
qu'il faut entretenir qu'il faut
chauffer en hiver votre collègue de
Ballan-Miré Thierry Chaillou appelle
l'état élargir le bouclier tarifaire à
toutes les communes vous le soutenez
dans cette démarche oui alors ce qu'on a
décidé sur ce sujet là je m'en suis
entretenu avec le président de la
métropole c'est que on va rassembler à
la fin de à la fin du mois de octobre un
conseil de sobriété énergétique qui va
regrouper tous les toutes les
collectivités tous les acteurs du monde
économique du monde commerçant du monde
associatif du monde citoyen les
bailleurs sociaux aussi vous avez vu que
les bailleurs sociaux ont des grosses
contraintes vous avez vu la
manifestation à Joué-lès-Tours parce que
voilà forcément les facteurs augmenter
donc on va avoir aussi ce bouillonnement
social qui nous inquiète donc on veut
faire un constat on veut partager les
bonnes pratiques et puis on veut aussi
alerter l'État sur les risques et les
périls qui que l'on a voilà dans les
différents domaines donc un vrai un vrai
rassemblement de l'ensemble des États
conseil de sobriété énergétique du
territoire et qui sera réuni à la fin du
mois en accord avec le président de la
métropole avec des décisions concrètes
qui sont prises à son issue l'objectif
c'est comme je vous l'ai dit on fait le
constat on partage les bonnes les bonnes
pratiques on cherche des nouvelles idées
et puis on a l'alerte l'État sur la
situation dans laquelle on est et les
risques qu'on a comme celui que vous
avez évoqué de devoir réduire les
services publics fermer des
établissements publics et puis ça c'est
le risque pour les collectivités mais il
y a les commerçants aussi qui sont en
difficulté le monde économique en
difficulté le monde associatif donc il
faut qu'on puisse remonter tout ça se
mobiliser collectivement donc c'est
l'objectif de cette de ce de se
rassemblement de ce conseil le long
terme cette fois c'est la rénovation des
bâtiments anciens ou leurs
reconstruction quels sont les bâtiments
prioritaires le calendrier alors nous on
a annoncé l'année dernière donc un plan
pluriannuel d'investissement de 450
millions pour de remettre à niveau les
bâtiments publics de la ville avec en
particulier le plan école qui
s'élève à plus de plus de 100 millions
de d'investissements le calendrier on a
la première école Jean de La Fontaine
qui est en cours de travaux on a Claude
Bernard donc on a environ une
demi-douzaine de d'écoles qui seront
rénovés ou reconstruites sur le mandat
et puis le reste sur les années à venir
c'est un plan plus réelle sur 12 ans si
l'état nous aide à augmenter nos
capacités d'investissement on pourra
aller plus vite là on est plutôt sur une
vision de ralentissement de notre PPI et
d'allongement de la durée des
investissements donc c'est là où on a
besoin de l'État pour les
investissements pour ne pas ralentir ces
investissements qui sont vraiment
nécessaires pour réduire notre facture
énergétique et aussi produire des
énergies renouvelables ce que ce qui est
manque cruellement aujourd'hui Antoine
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière
puisque 15% si on y ajoute les bases
décidé par le gouvernement
sera pas suffisant pour financer ce plan
pluriel ça sera suffisant ça va nous
permettre de financer mais le problème
c'est que si les factures énergétiques
compensent finalement les recettes dans
la facture et bien voilà donc on va les
marges de manœuvre supplémentaires qui
nous auraient permis de d'accélérer ce
plan de rénovation et bien vont passer
dans cette facture énergétique c'est
pour ça que les États doit nous aider
vraiment avec un bouclier comme le dit
mon collègue un bouclier tarifaire pour
que on ne soit pas obligé de réduire
notre nos marges de manœuvre sur les
investissements l'écologie encore c'est
le vélo les mobilités douces vous l'avez
dit la marche les transports en commun
également tout ça en lien avec la
métropole qui en a la compétence un plan
vélo avec 350 km de piste cyclables a
été adopté il y a 6 mois pour un coût
total de 180 millions d'euros ou en
est-on de ce plan vélo quel est le
calendrier là alors le calendrier c'est
qu'on a
choisi la maîtrise d'oeuvre donc ceux
qui vont réaliser les travaux qui
commenceront dès 2023 et donc l'objectif
c'est sur 2023 déjà pour la ville de
Tours d'avoir un raccordement du nord de
la ville jusqu'au pont Wilson ou au pont
de fil pour se raccorder finalement aux
travaux qu'on a déjà fait sur la ville
de Tours parce qu'on a pas attendu le
plan métropolitain il y a eu le pont
Wilson il y a eu la rue de Buffon il y a
eu la rue Édouard vaillant il y a la
vélo rue que l'on a commencé à
expérimenter cet été qui fonctionnait
extrêmement bien j'ai les derniers
chiffres on était à 650 vélos par jour
en juin avant la vélo rue et là on a
doublé on a mesuré cette semaine 1300
vélos par jour ça veut dire que voilà ça
fonctionne ça veut dire qu'il y a des
cyclistes qui s'emparent de ces de ces
parcours sécurisés et donc on va
continuer on va accélérer cela et donc
avec la maîtrise d'oeuvre de la de la
métropole et les financements que vous
avez évoqué on va pouvoir aller beaucoup
plus vite avec pour laver le rue
certains riverains qui se plaignent d'un
délestage de la circulation sur la rue
Victor Hugo est-ce que il va y avoir une
autre vélo rue du coup sur Victor Hugo
les CV ne font que reporter la
circulation alors il y a toujours des
modifications de fonctionnement il y a
toujours bien sûr au début des habitudes
qui doivent être changées l'objectif et
on a été élu pour ça c'est de reprendre
un peu de place à la voiture et de
permettre de faciliter de sécuriser les
le passage en vélo dans les rues donc
voilà il y a des ajustements je vais
rencontrer les personnes qui sont
mécontent on va trouver des solutions
mais on ne reviendra pas en arrière il
faut il faut absolument développer les
pistes cyclables sur tour comme on l'a
déjà fait et ça fonctionne le pont
Wilson c'est plus 30% par rapport à 2019
donc ça fonctionne quand on met en place
ces infrastructures les gens s'emparent
du vélo et c'est comme ça que on peut
avoir des parts modales qui se modifient
et c'est comme ça qu'on peut avoir moins
de voitures en ville et donc au final
ces bénéfique pour tous alors c'est
peut-être des petits désagréments des
petites habitudes à changer mais au
global c'est vraiment positif et c'est
pour ça qu'on a été élu alors il y a un
service de
vocation indigo wheel qui avait été mise
en place avant d'être supprimé on va
écouter justement ce que dit un tour en
jeu à ce propos
il y a à peu près deux trois ans il
faisait des indigo Wils c'était des
vélos où on pouvait prendre et aller un
petit peu partout on voulait et c'était
vachement pratique à la fois pour se
déplacer à aller au boulot et éviter de
prendre la voiture mais aussi par
exemple pour rentrer de soirée c'était
sympa aussi et je sais pas pourquoi ils
ont enlevé ça peut-être qu'il y avait
trop de vandalisme dessus je sais pas
exactement c'est dangereux de se
promener à vélo à Tours donc il faudrait
des picyclaves plus sécurisées alors
vous l'avez dit la sécurité sécurisez
les pistes cyclables et puis service de
vélo
il y a une réflexion voilà
la première expérience n'a pas
fonctionné donc on est en train de
regarder pour mettre en place les
conditions pour que ça fonctionne mieux
avec d'autres opérateurs on sait pas
encore si ce sera des trottinettes
électriques ou si ce sera encore des des
vélos mais c'est en train de d'être
regardé on y reviendra parce que c'est
des solutions d'avenir pour la société
donc et c'était il y a deux ans
maintenant depuis le covid il y a une
accélération de l'engouement pour le
vélo et donc là on pense que c'est le
bon moment de retenter avec un nouvel
opérateur avec des conditions peut-être
un peu différentes mais bien sûr on a
vocation à avoir de ce type de solution
qui se développe partout à quel horizon
je pense que sur 2023
on pourra on pourra avoir une solution
une nouvelle solution de ce type là on
va parler de réchauffement climatique
enfin à la façon dont on se prépare pour
affronter des étés de plus en plus
caniculaire parlons d'abord de ce projet
privé de campus indédié aux énergies
renouvelables en lui et place de l'école
Polytech des deux lions qui doit voir le
jour en 2027 quelle formation
pourrait-on y trouver finalement ce que
vous avez faite lors du dernier conseil
municipal ouais alors c'est un très beau
projet d'avenir c'est un projet privé
mais on a besoin des acteurs privés bien
sûr pour faire cette transition
écologique qui regroupera à la fois mon
un peu de logement étudiant mais aussi
un green tech
Center c'est un green data center c'est
à dire voilà l'équivalent de ce qu'on a
avec Google et Amazon mais
vertueux c'est à dire à Data Center qui
consomme peu d'énergie et qui consomment
peu de ressources et puis un CFA de la
formation autour de l'entreprise enerlis
qui est à la pointe sur les énergies
renouvelables qui fera de la R&D qui
travaillera sur l'hydrogène et qui
proposera aussi une formation type CFA
sur les métiers du de des énergies
renouvelables en particulier du photo du
photovoltaï et puis il y aura l'accueil
de start-up sur les lothèques sur les
énergies renouvelables l'idée c'est de
développer un peu ce tissu autour des
énergies de demain et c'est vraiment ça
c'est en totale résonance avec ce qui se
passe avec la crise énergétique on en a
besoin donc ça sera un projet majeur et
vraiment pilier pour pour le territoire
il nous reste une de temps pour une
dernière question
parlons de cette verdure en centre-ville
de Tours alors ça n'a pas marché pour
les arbres de la rue Nationale que
quelle plante proposez-vous justement
pour reverdir tour alors ça marchera
pour les
arbres qui ont été était avait été
abîmée pendant le transport donc on va
les changer les planter au bon moment on
va prendre les bonnes essences et ça
fonctionnera et on aura de l'ombre rue
Nationale on va faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne et puis parallèlement à ça on
a un plan nature de revégétalisation des
cours d'école ça marche très très bien
vous l'avez vu ça a été illustré même
dans les médias nationaux et demain je
vais inaugurer d'ailleurs à l'école
buisson Molière la revégétalisation de
l'école donc ça ce sont des îlots de
chaleur là où nos enfants
vont à l'école qui qui vont se
développer on en aura une quinzaine sur
la ville et puis certaines places comme
la place pilorgée où on va revégétaliser
supprimer le bitume et puis faire en
sorte que on est des
îlots de fraîcheur des refuges
finalement quand les températures sont
extrêmement fortes il peut y avoir des
écarts de 6 à 7 degrés exactement ça
vous avez un spécialiste de ces îlots de
chaleur dans votre équipe municipale
merci beaucoup Emmanuel denimer élever
de Tours d'être venu ce soir sur notre
plateau
et c'est la fin de cette interview
politique merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
très bonne soirée